joining us now reaction of the New York
Times best-selling book vengeance former
Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor Newt Gingrich's with us mr.
speaker welcome back and Happy New Year
sir Happy New Year it's great to be with
you and I think it's gonna be a great
year you know so you're writing I think
it was the most viewed on foxnews.com
underestimate Trump at your own peril
and then 2018 get ready for the
political surprise of 2018 because I'm
watching and listening to everyone else
in the media and they think this this is
going to be the biggest beat-down for
Republicans and we've ever seen well I
you know I keep trying to remind people
that all these folks who are currently
analyzing on Sunday morning talk shows
were the same people who were wrong in
2015 about whether or not Trump could be
a candidate they were wrong in 2016
about whether or not he could win the
nomination they were wrong in the fall
of 2016
about whether or not he could beat
Hillary and they've been wrong for all
of 2017 so I started with the idea I
listen to them carefully take exactly
the opposite position and almost every
time I'm doing better than they are and
I think this is gonna be a good year
I think the tax cut bill is so central
to the future of America and the
philosophy behind it of lower taxes more
take-home pay more job creation better
business environment is so central to
what makes America tick that I think the
Democrats who've unanimously voted no
think about that deshaun they
unanimously voted for higher taxes
bigger bureaucracy fewer jobs so the
Democratic parties offer is you're going
to be out of work well we'll get you
food stamps I think that's a losing
proposition so assuming that after a
year of investigating Trump Russia
collusion and coming up with unrelated
charges for Paul Manafort general Flynn
lying to the FBI we now find ourselves
in a position and we'll get into this in
great detail where there are issues
about collusion and that would be
Hillary funding the dossier
paid for with Russian lies
misinformation propaganda all to
influence an election should that be a
big issue or or come--and Peter struck
writing an exoneration before an
investigation or the Iranian one issue
why would anyone have ever allowed 20%
of America's uranium to go to Vladimir
Putin especially knowing about bribery
extortion kickbacks and money laundering
you know a year and a half earlier
robert muller knew about it so did the
republic does the republican party have
an obligation now to go after what we
did find as a result of the
investigation that the democrats never
really expected to find look I don't
think it's just about Republicans or
Democrats the very core of the United
States is a belief in the rule of law
because it's the rule of law which
protects the weak from the strong it's
the rule of law which protects the poor
from the rich it's the rule of law which
autumn Lee protects every citizen from
their own government we have an
obligation as Americans to want to know
whether or not the Justice Department
had been corrupted whether or not senior
leaders of the FBI had been corrupted we
have an obligation to find out whether
or not they were putting in position of
power people who were so totally biased
that they couldn't possibly be part of a
Department of Justice they had to be a
part of that part of a department that
was going to go after and persecute
people and I think that what you've
raised as the tip of the iceberg I think
we're going to find out during the
course of this year about a great deal
of mismanagement and inappropriate
behavior in the FBI and the senior level
in the Justice to the State Department
and I think we're going to go back and
we're going to end in the State
Department and we're going to go back
and we're going to learn a great deal
more about the corruption inherent in
the Clinton Foundation and the
corruption inherent in the entire
investigation of Hillary so I don't see
how you can walk off it's not a question
about a vendetta against the person how
do you have this scale scandal and just
walk off and forget it particularly what
has just happened last week we
learned that Huma Abedin had an
additional set of emails at least four
of which were classified and password
her husband's laptop and unbelievable
alright let me ask you about Iran four
months ago when the president was
speaking at the United Nations he
predicted there would be an Iranian the
Iranian people would revolt now we have
Iranian protesters attacking police
stations they stormed an Iranian
military base according to reports and
they are chanting death to the Ayatollah
very different than the green movement
in 2009 now we have a president
supporting those people that want
Liberty freedom maybe even
constitutional government if you're the
president what do you do now to help
those protesters well let me say first
of all my newsletter tomorrow is going
to be President Trump Iran and leading
from the front the opposite of Obama's
famous leading from the rear comment
second I think we have an obligation to
first of all maximize the production of
our various radio and television
programming going into Iran I think we
should be gathering up and I understand
from from ambassador Haley that that
they're likely to ask for United Nations
Security Council meeting on this issue I
think we should be putting real pressure
on the Europeans they're always pious
about human rights well here's a chance
to stand up with us we should be doing
what the president has done to his
credit which is issuing very strong
warnings against the Iranian
dictatorship killing its own citizens
and I would hope when they come back
next week that the House and Senate will
pass very strong resolutions condemning
the dictatorship I mean here is a clear
definition moment when it's impossible
to believe that the dictatorship is a
popular government now this is a
repressive brutal dictatorship it killed
over I think there's over 30,000 people
in 1988 I'm afraid that they're prepared
to come back and kill a lot of people we
should be very aggressively publicly
opposed
using that alright mr. speaker happy new
year great to see you